so yeah unfortunately we couldn't be
there with you you know it's still a bit
complicated to travel uh europe wide
and beyond uh but we are mit and i we're
very happy to be uh there even if only
virtually with you
to speak about choreography versus
orchestration in um serverless
microservices or microservices in
general
so i'm kim laforge i'm a developer
advocate for google cloud
and i'm based in paris and today i'm
with mete
hi everyone my name is mata tamel i am
also a developer advocate at google
based in london and as guillaume
mentioned um
we are sure that we are not there i mean
nbc oslo is one of my favorite
conferences and i spoke there a few
times uh but this time we couldn't make
it there
um but hopefully this will be good
enough and um if you have any questions
uh please
try to put them on a slido and i will be
monitoring that as we go along and i
will try to answer them and also in the
end we should have some time so we'll
check it there as well
and i understand that there is also a
chance to ask questions and why i might
in the end um so maybe we'll do that in
the end as well depending on the time
but yeah feel free to ask questions as
we go along because we like this to be
an interactive session so thanks very
much
all right thank you um so yeah we'll be
speaking about choreography versus
orchestration and we'll explain what
those two approaches or concepts
uh are
so of course that's not about that kind
of choreography and orchestration
although there are some you know similar
um or similitude let's say
uh we're going to so it's really two
architectural uh approaches and
different ways of messaging uh and
having microservices interact with each
other uh but what we are going to do um
so we'll go through the different
approaches uh but really uh
look i'm looking forward to the end
where we speak about a concrete use case
uh meter and i built an application uh
called the pico daily picture sharing
application and uh this uh
talk is actually the um our learned
experiences uh while we were building
and rewriting this uh application
together so stay tuned
especially till the end where we cover
uh our feedback uh that we learned along
the way when building those applications
so
um
let's first have a look at a simple
e-commerce kind of
uh transaction where you have multiple
services and different technologies
here i've illustrated uh with a few
icons from google cloud products but it
doesn't have to be about google cloud at
all so imagine any technology that you
prefer any
framework etc
so we have a front-end application
that's going to receive some incoming
requests from
users we have a second service that's a
payment processor to
to you know authorize and charge a
credit card then we have a cheaper
service that's going to prepare and ship
the items as well as a notification
service that is going to notify our
users whether the transaction was
successful with whether the uh the
parcels will be uh
um you know delivered to to their
address etc so one approach uh is to
potentially chain those micro services
so the front end calls the payment
processor when the pro the payment
processing is done the payment processor
is going to call the shipper to prepare
the the order and then once the the
order is ready uh perhaps this last
cheaper service is going to call yet
another
service so it's a it's a kind of a chain
uh
of services
so uh it's one approach but as you can
see
the services are pretty tightly coupled
as they invoke each other in a chain so
if something fails in the middle what's
going to happen right
so there are some pros and cons uh to
this approach so if you look so let's
imagine we're using rest to have
each service called each other
when you use a
this approach usually we've already
split
potentially a big monolith into smaller
micro services so it's easier to work on
individual services
because you can also have teams focus
different teams focusing on different
services rather than having to
you know ensure that the monolith is
still in a consistent state
uh it's pretty easy to implement as well
in the sense that services simply call
each other uh beyond rest so it's pretty
straightforward to do however in terms
of cons well there's indeed too much
coupling between all the services
especially when one service fails uh
what happens to the the overall uh
the the overall transaction
uh also the other thing that might be
tricky tricky is how
error reporting or retry and timeout
logic works in this context because it's
really at the
service invocation point where you have
to handle this so you have to add some
technical or
infrastructure related code at
invocation site
and uh it's going to you know i some
boilerplate code inside your
business code basically so it's not
necessarily always super clean to to do
it that way well depending on the
technology or framework you use
things might be a better or or not
another an alternative approach would be
to use a an even driven approach that's
the choreography pattern basically where
uh instead of having a service called
another studies which calls
another service etc in chain here we're
going to use some kind of message broker
so it can be some
pub sub kind of
product with topics subscriptions etc so
here the front end is going to send a
message through the broker saying hey
i've got a new request then uh service
the payment processor is going to listen
to a particular topic and oh yeah
there's a an incoming payment processing
request okay i'm gonna handle it uh if
the if i can charge this credit card
then i'm going to send another event
another message then the shipper service
might be interested in that particular
message etc the notifier might be
interested in the
shipping uh
messages as well etc so it's more
loosely coupled uh there's no i mean
there's no responsibility for one
service you know to call the other
service
so things are also more usable so
potentially let's say the cheaper
service might be used by other
parts uh of your application or the
notification which is more
generic perhaps
and the uh it's easier as well to
scale or reuse
those
services and scale them potentially
independently
depending on how much one particular
service is used so if we look again at
uh
another but
slightly more complex example uh let's
say here uh you've got
you you've got to check uh what's in the
inventory perhaps you're going to call
the inventory database
and have different branches
so
in one branch
it's in the inventory so you can prepare
the order confirmation if it's out of
stock then you might need to call a
supplier api to uh replenish the stock
uh prepare some some messages etc
then uh in either
path in either branch uh you also have
to update the inventory prepare the
order notify the customer depending
perhaps on the uh if it's big order
perhaps you want to involve the sales
rep or not so you might have different
branches so compared to the previous
example where it was still chain of
messages things were pretty much serial
here we see that for more complex
business processes
um
message driven approach
still interesting but perhaps it's
harder to
make sense of the the flow of messages
that are you know flowing around in our
system
so
pros and cons again um
so in terms of pros services are loosely
coupled which which is nice which is a
nice characteristic services can be
changed and scaled independently
which is also a good thing there's no
single point of failure because even if
a service goes down
then well it'll pick up uh the the the
messages when it's ready again to serve
uh those those messages
and uh
another nice characteristic of this
approach is that uh events are usually
easy to extend even eventing system are
easy to extend in the sense that
potentially there's a new event
that is going to be created
and
new services or existing services might
be interested in that new event or
if there's a new service interested in
an existing event you can also add that
service fairly easily without changing
the overall uh architecture et cetera so
it's it's very easy to add new messages
new kind of events and uh new services
in terms of uh cons
it's usually harder to monitor the whole
system it's more complicated to figure
out okay this particular message trigger
this flow of messages so you have to
keep track of some correlation ids and
things like that to ensure that
those messages are somewhat correlated
in terms of errors retries come out it's
uh it's still complicated you might be
able to set some logic at the
perhaps the pub sub system so for
this particular queue or topic of
messages then you won't have retries and
that many retries but it might be
pretty much global to that topic and not
on a per service usage
perspective
the other downside i would say uh is the
fact that the business floor is not
really captured explicitly in the sense
that
the uh
the behavior of your application the
behavior of your business process is
emerging out of the flow of messages of
events
but there's not a really a place where
you can look at and say okay so it
should like in our flow chart basically
you don't have a flowchart saying okay
it's going here and there it's going to
call this other service because that
even is going to trigger
that service etc so it's uh not easy to
monitor
track and thus also understand uh what's
going on uh
with this flow of messages and events
and also who ensures that the whole
transaction is successful um okay you've
got messages flying around but you don't
necessarily have uh
let's say a more global service that
would ensure that
well all those messages
led to
the end of our
workforce of our business process
um
mete you want to say a few words about
the uh orchestration approach a
different approach yes so let me share
my screen and
you can let me know
stop sharing this is your turn
okay so you can see my screen
yes okay um and by the way someone
mentioned in the in the questions uh to
try to zoom in in our um
slides i'm sharing the full screen so i
don't know how i can zoom in more uh but
oh yeah let's keep that in mind let's
when we show calling later we'll try to
zoom in as much as we can
okay um so as guillermo described so
when we are
designing an architecture we can have
services calling each other directly and
that has these issues of tight coupling
and then we can go with a choreography
or event driven approach where things
are more loosely coupled but then all of
a sudden you have this mess with
messages where you have all these
different message types that are flying
around and then it becomes really hard
to monitor your system and most
importantly
um
[Music]
like there's nobody ensuring that the
transaction is successful of course
there are some patterns like saga
pattern that you can use to kind of
make sure that
transactions that are successful and
then if something fails you can apply
compensation things um but there's no
nothing like overall like uh watching
your your events and inventory system
working correctly so you need to kind of
think about that how you're going to do
that
now another approach you can take it's
called orchestration
and in this approach instead of services
calling each other or instead of
services sending messages
indirectly to each other
you can have as an external service
orchestrating the calls in the order
that you want so if you go back to our
previous simple example or an e-commerce
transaction
in this case um you can have the
front-end
receiving the request like before
and then the front-end kicks off an
orchestration so there's an external
orchestrator uh by the way this
orchestrator it doesn't have to be
external per se like so for example you
can have the front end
kind of orchestrate things if you like
or you can have one of your services
kind of orchestrating other services so
it is possible to kind of do
orchestration um
within your front end or or with maybe
in a service within your architecture
but it is usually a better idea to have
something external and we'll talk more
about this when we talk about workflows
so typically this is an external service
that whose job is to really orchestrate
your calls and what this orchestrator
can do is that it can
first of all it has the rules um
all your business logic so whatever you
want to do whatever services you want to
call in in whatever form you kind of
um
explain that in your orchestration and
we'll get to this again when we talk
about uh workflows uh and then the
orchestrator just follows those rules
and then in this case it will call the
payment processor and then the shipper
and the notifier so it will make those
step calls to each service and since
orchestrator is the one calling these it
can make sure that each step is
successful so for example if something
happens with payment processor
orchestrator can rewrite the call
it can also take
results back so if payment processor
returns something okay so it can take
that result and it can pass that result
to the next uh service like the shipper
for example
so in this approach
of course there's a pros and cons the
pros is that the business flow like how
things should flow can be captured
centrally and since it can be captured
centrally it can be source controlled
and this is really really uh useful um
because you have this central place
where you can say this is the this is
how things are supposed to work you can
virgin that so you can have multiple
versions and if something needs to
change you can have a new version and
you can you can source control this so
if someone comes to your system and they
want to know how the system is supposed
to work there's a place you can they can
go and look at it and they can see the
history of it as well since you're
versioning it
now each step can be monitored um in
orchestration there's steps and if if a
step fails it it's very obvious like
what failed uh again we'll look at this
uh when we show our example
um these errors retries and timeouts
that you need to think about they can be
now centralized
because if you want to for example apply
a central
kind of error policy uh
you can apply that in each step in your
orchestration rather than implementing
that
error policy within each of your
microservices so that allows your
services to be
more simple they just do the the
business logic but they don't really
need to deal with the retry logic or the
error logic that all microsources need
to deal with usually
and the good news is that the services
are still independent right there are
still micro services that are deployed
independently that can be scaled
independently uh but you are kind of
bringing them together
into what i call a temporary monolithic
application right like the orchestration
if you think about it is kind of like
bringing these uh services that are
independent into a temporary metamorph
kind of situation so you are kind of
getting the best of both worlds the
independence of microservices
versus the
the coupling that you get and the
benefits that you get from the coupling
with an orchestration kind of like a
monolith
um but an orchestration service it's
something new to learn and maintain um
and it's a different kind of paradigm
than what you might be used to because
usually we're used to independent
services calling each other or or events
flying around but an orchestration is
basically an e
a a new service that you need to
configure
and define how it's going to hold these
um
services and then if you need to change
something the orchestration needs to
change as well so that's something uh
that you need to get used to
orchestrator could be a single point of
failure
because if orchestration source doesn't
run then nothing gets run so you need to
make sure that you're using something
resilient and redundant
and you are losing the some flexibility
by choosing orchestration right because
in eventing
for example if you want to add a new
service um all you need to do is deploy
the service and
configure
what messages that service should
receive right that's really it so the
configuration is quite quite simple
whereas in orchestration
you need to do more you need to deploy
the service and you need to also change
your orchestration and take that service
into account and you need to deploy your
orchestration again usually right so
that give that makes it a little bit
harder to extend your system and you're
losing a little bit of flexibility there
and you still need to think about
the
the whole transaction
now
the orchestrator
is the thing that can watch your whole
flow so you can it can watch that all
steps are successful so in that sense
we're doing better right like we're
making sure that each step can be
successful and if all the steps like
worked
then your whole transaction is
successful so in that sense it's better
than eventing and i think it's easier
than inventing in terms of
how to make sure the whole transaction
is successful
but you still need to worry about what
happens when a step fails in the middle
right then you need to do what's called
compensation steps right so if something
fails like let's say you charge the user
and then you want to ship an item
afterwards but shipping the item failed
or maybe you run out of stock or
something like that now you need to go
back and uncharge the user or maybe
remove the block from the credit card so
you need to have this compensation step
so you need to implement the saga
pattern again um but
i guess it becomes a little bit easier
to do the saga python because um
orchestration services they
give you tools to kind of capture
the the errors and and add new steps to
handle them um like do do kind of try
catches in your steps if you will
all right so the question is like which
one is better choreography orchestration
which one should i use um
you know it depends as in every software
engineering question
but there are certain um
things that i look for uh when i'm
thinking about my architecture
so
if my services are not cluster related
meaning
you know you have these services that
are independent they don't really need
to know about each other and they can
also exist in different kind of
transactions
then in that case
usually an event-driven system
is better because these services
they can
live in different contexts and it will
be easier to plug them in
into those contexts if you're using
eventing right so that's when i start
thinking about event driven
but on the other hand
if your services are closely related
meaning they usually are deployed
together
and they usually call each other in a
certain order
then that's when i start thinking
orchestration because if you if your
services kind of act like a unit already
then why bother with the eventing
flexibility you don't really need that
flexibility
also
um if you can define your flow of your
services in a flowchart like the example
that guillaume showed with that
flowchart
then usually that's a good candidate for
orchestration because that flow chart
has a lot of useful information about
how your system should work
and if you want to preserve that
orchestration allows you to actually
quantify that well first of all
orchestration allows you to
kind of code that in orchestration and
then it also allows you to preserve that
and version that so if that's important
to you then orchestration is probably a
better option
and of course um you can also take a
hybrid approach
uh and i think this is what i usually
see in real world kind of applications
like you don't really go with
just event driven or you don't really go
with just orchestration but you usually
go with a mix of both when it makes
sense
so what you can do is that you can
orchestrate
what makes sense together so if there's
a transaction with a multiple services
that makes sense to go together all the
time then you orchestrate that but then
at the end of the transaction
you might want to um
signal other orchestrations with
eventing because they don't really need
to know about each other they just need
to be able to signal to each other right
so for that you can use event driven
similarly you can
have your orchestration be triggered by
an event and for example a user saves an
image to a bucket and you want that
event to trigger orchestration or image
processing right so that's a perfect
candidate for an event triggered
triggering
the orchestration and then your
orchestration taking over and doing the
work
that it needs to do in a tightly coupled
way with the services that you have
right okay um so that was a really quick
summary of uh choreography orchestration
uh now guillaume will tell us
what kind of services and tools exist in
this landscape
and then after that we'll get back to
orchestration and look at in more detail
on google cloud workforce
yeah thank you mate and we actually have
a question uh an interesting one if we
have an error on some step and we need
to show it on the ui do we better notify
ui directly or via orchestration
i guess it depends again a bit on the
situation but for example on a recent
application that i built so i had
a it was a small uh
well it was a demo it wasn't a real
application but uh i created a an
expense report application
and um um
sometimes let's say you're
sending some research that are not valid
or things like this
uh or i wanted to
see what was the
ongoing state or status of
that particular
expense report uh so i was using um
in that particular application at least
i was using the firestore realtime
database to actually notify of status
changes
so if there's an error i can notify you
with that if there's uh you know if i'm
just going to the next step i want to
update and say okay this is the uh uh
we're currently in this but in this
particular step so i actually in my
workflow definition i actually had steps
to update
the the status basically so if i wanted
to say okay the expense report was
submitted or the
the receipts uh are not correct
i could just update the ui thanks to
this real-time notification mechanism
which was
because that's a real-time kind of
database uh i was able from the front
end to check what was the the ongoing
status basically so yeah we can we can
show it on the ui and it can be a step
of the the actual
uh orchestration of the the workflow
definition
another um question could you combine
choreographing on orchestration yes
that's
what mette explained
especially when you've got several
bounded contacts uh you might have the
bigger picture might be
actually a
choreography of events but then for
well-defined bounded context kind of
business processes then there it's a
great idea to use uh orchestration
instead so you can combine the two and
in bigger systems i think that would be
the norm to have several uh the two
approaches together
all right so let me share my screen
again
share
okay
all right so let me uh say a few words
about the landscape
so
for
even driven systems for choreography i
mean all the uh cloud providers have
well there are several solutions for for
each cloud providers
for aws for azure for google cloud so
for on google cloud you can use pub sub
or you can use even art or
events
but there are also uh
things we're seeing a lot in in the wild
uh some some well-known open source
projects
uh that are being used like kafka apache
pulsar etc i'm often seeing kafka being
used for uh even driven systems
and quite successfully
but yeah all the the big cloud providers
either offer their own solutions or
some integration as well with
those
open source projects
in terms of orchestration same thing so
for example
uh unleaded
aws you can combine lambda functions
with step functions on azure you've got
logic apps on google cloud you've got
cloud composer which is based on the
apache airflow open source project uh
composer is more for or airflow is more
for data-driven kind of pipelines and
business processes whereas workflows
that's the project um and product will
be using uh in our demonstration uh
workflow is more for uh yeah business
processes uh with you know
some logic like branching and things
like that and not necessarily data
driven
with uh so i'm just going to show those
two screens very quickly we don't have
to look into the details but we try to
have a look at the orchestration
products so step functions uh logic apps
and google cloud workflows
uh and basically those three products
have more or less the same coverage
uh but we've been trying to keep track
on some of the the features that are
available but yeah all things like
branching logic
var steps calling uh apis etc that's uh
the kind of steps you can usually either
kind of actions you can usually do
in those kind of
products and that's uh
and will have yeah you wanted to add
something
yeah i just want to add a couple of
things here um so
for when we did this research one theme
that emerges that the base features are
there for
most all club providers so the base kind
of orchestration is there but step
functions it seems to be more geared
towards um
aws ecosystem so you can
orchestrate
aws lambda and other aws services but
they don't really allow you to
orchestrate external services and i
think that's a serious limitation that
you should be aware of um on the other
hand logic apps um seems to be the most
um feature rich orchestrator per se they
let you orchestrate pretty much
everything on azure and outside azure
and they also have a really rich
ecosystem of
external things that you can pull in
um and nice features like you know
including um code in your
steps
that run quickly things like that um so
that seems to be the most fully
feature-rich one workflows is close
second with most of the main features
and the step functions is mostly for
aws ecosystem yeah
and uh
we have a few questions and i'll take
them as we go so is it ideal and
feasible for an orchestrator to be
simple enough that it can demand a
hundred percent test coverage
um
[Music]
potentially yes uh uh
i mean that maybe
so first of all when we use an
orchestrator um
since it's a product that you use you
don't necessarily have um
uh
since it's a cloud-based here at least
in the ones we're mentioning uh our
cloud-based uh
it's complicated to do
uh unit tests you really have to do
integration tests
uh and
depending on how complicated the
workflow is so we've got if you've got
tons and tons of branches
and conditions etc the combinatorial
explosion
will might make it difficult and
complicated to have a hundred percent
test coverage so i wouldn't necessarily
go as far as requiring uh that high
level of coverage
um
do you agree mate
yeah i mean it's hard to unit test
orchestrator
at least at this stage um
but um
but i think um yeah you basically have
to do like some kind of integration
testing to test your full orchestration
and that's the story today but that
might change with these open source
projects that guillaume is going to talk
about right now
sorry
yeah and by the way but someone asked if
these slides are available yeah they're
already available actually i will put a
link in as a question there so that
people know where it is
thanks mitten
yeah so another thing uh you might want
to have a look at it's the the cncf uh
severalist workflow
um it's it's actually a new um something
fairly new that that landed or it's
still an incubation i think uh at the
cncf uh so it's a specification uh
to um for defining uh workforce with a
kind of dsl or domain-specific language
and also providing various sdks so that
developers can call
that workflow
um
and but but then there are uh two things
it's still fairly new and uh all the the
products we've mentioned
as as far as i know at least no one
currently implement that specification
uh
so
you know your mileage may it may vary
but until at least one or more providers
or open source projects uh implement
that specification it's not of much use
yet
but the other interesting aspects of
this
this project
it's also that it's using the cloud
events uh specification it's another
specification that describes uh and
standardizes the format of events for um
even driven even
payloads and another thing that it's
taking advantage of it's the the open
api specification uh to describe your
services so the services you want to
interact with within your servers
workflow
have to be described with open api so
they have to be uh rest and you have to
provide an open api description for them
but it's uh interesting to keep an eye
on this and see how it evolves and if
uh cloud providers uh adopt this this
standard this specification
uh i'll zoom in uh i know that's a
method that's going to zoom in on
one particular example which is google
cloud workflows
yes so let me
just
get in there
all right so now
in the rest of the time i want to talk
about workflows and my point here is
that i want to show you what you can
expect from an orchestrator and we are
going to use google cloud workflows as
an example because that's what we know
but you can expect similar things from
logic apps and other step functions uh
similar things uh just to give you an
idea on what you can expect from
orchestrator and then we'll talk about
our case study um
at the end
to show you how we use these tools
basically in an app that we wrote
okay um
so what is workflows workflows it's a
service to orchestrate and integrate
other services basically and the things
that you can orchestrate is first of all
your code running on google cloud
and by the way it doesn't have to be
serverless code so any code that you
have running that has
that you can access from the cloud uh
workflows can include in your
orchestration so this can be service
functions service containers
uh web applications with app engine or
even
your app running on virtual machines as
long as it can be accessible with http
okay
so any code that you have any google api
or google cloud api that you might want
to call and any external apis as well so
this allows you to write orchestration
where you combine your code
the apis of the cloud and also external
apis like twitter api or
tooli or something like that that you
might want to include in your
orchestration and i like this because i
i think in a typical kind of
workflow orchestration it's not just
about your code it's kind of a
combination of many things right so this
allows you to include those in your
orchestration
now how do you define your workflow
um well there is a workflow definition
language and this language can be in
yaml or json uh by the way uh sorry for
the mode i don't think yaml is meant for
this but this is what we have uh i think
we can blame kubernetes for all this
yaml craziness but anyway so we have
this
um definition language and
in there you have this idea of steps so
you you define and name your steps and
you define what happens in steps and you
define inputs to your steps and output
your steps and and and so on and so
forth so if we look at our previous
example of these three services calling
each other
you would orchestrate this using
something like this
where you define three steps
and then in each step you define what
happens so here we are saying that we
are called making an http post call
to the url which is the url of the cloud
run service and then we are passing in
the input or payment details that we
received as a parameter so you receive
it from the previous step and then we
pass it as an input to the
to this step now once this is so this
call is going to be made by workflows
and then once you have a result and you
can capture that in a in a variable
called process result
and then in the next step again you can
you can take this and you can parse it
you do a little bit of json parsing and
provide it as an input now to a cloud
function so you see how this works like
defining the steps and passing the
variables and passing it a little bit as
you go along so
this step sequencing
is what orchestration is about
uh you can do things like serverless
pause so let's say you ship an item but
you want to wait a little bit before you
notify the user so the orchestration can
kind of add a timer and weight
um and then as i mentioned you
you can pass parameters between your
functions
and you can kind of do a little bit of
json parsing um when once you receive a
parameter you can pass what you need and
just pass that part although i have to
warn you that this json parsing is very
primitive so if you need to do something
more complicated it's not there yet but
it allows like basic parsing
now so that's steps um then on top of
that you can
have errors error handling in workflows
so for example if in payment processor
if you want to make sure that you retry
a few times before you fail the step you
can specify this maximum five times an
exponential back-off policy for that
step and workflows will do that for you
um this is very useful it kind of takes
out the
error and recreate logic out of your
functions or containers and
and make
gives you a way to do it globally with
from the workflow
also
sometimes
you know maybe you want to do different
things depending on the outcome of a
function so if a function is successful
you might want to call do not fire
service but the function is not
successful you get an error
error and by success an error i mean the
http code that you get back
um but you can define that precisely
what it means to successful or error
and then depending on that you can
branch to another service and you can
maybe call the pager service so that
kind of logic can can be part of your
orchestration rather than trying to do
it in the code
and
um
this conditional sometimes you want to
do something you want to read like say
the database and check a value and
determine if if something is in stock
out of stock and do different things
depending on that right so that
conditional logic is very easy to do in
workflows you have a switch statements
and you can basically switch switch and
do different things
and this
third-party api calls like let's say at
some point you want to request something
from a supplier um that can be part of
your orchestration as well uh that you
don't need to
kind of deploy code to do that
the workforce can call that for you
and to wrap it up um there's some other
useful features like you can define sub
workflows to encapsulate common reusable
workflows and use them from multiple
places
we have connectors to connect to google
cloud services um
so this instead of trying to construct
http call from your orchestration you
can use connectors and connectors make
it easier to to call
google cloud services and also have the
logic to retry things if something needs
to be retried or wait for things
and there's the notion of iteration so
in your workflow you can do for loops
basically let's say you want to call it
twitter api get some tweets and then for
each tweet do something
so you want to do that in your for loop
you can do that
we have callbacks
which allows you to write orchestrations
with people in the loop so let's say you
have some orchestration running and at
some point someone needs to approve the
next step then you can have a callback
that waits and the
an external user can send an http
request to the callback to continue the
rest of the orchestration so features
like this help a lot to build pretty
sophisticated orchestrations
to deploy a workflow you can do it from
command line so you define your yaml and
deploy this deploys the workflow but it
doesn't
execute it to execute it you run another
command and then you can see the
execution
by describing the workflow
and all of this is also from the ui so
if you go to google cloud console um you
can see the orchestration defined here
and you can see the visualization of the
orchestration in here and i think if we
have time we'll show you this uh in our
example but this visualization is really
useful um to kind of visualize how
things are supposed to flow in your
system and then you can execute it here
you can see the logs here um if execute
and you can see the executions under
here and if execution failed you can see
what step failed things like that but
we'll take a look at this um let me show
the application
all right so let in the last 20 minutes
or so let's talk about our case study so
i will hand over to guillaume to talk
about this app and the choreographer
part of that app now thanks again
thank you uh
and
i'm going to share my screen
all right yeah and uh
there are a couple of questions so let's
uh have a quick look at them so there
was a
a question about uh azure orchestration
functions orchestration versus logic
apps
so
i'm not uh perhaps you've got uh some
more info on this method you looked at
uh
yeah so i think they mean as you're the
azure has drawable functions uh where it
allows you to call other functions um so
in that sense it is an orchestrator but
um from what i see in it's basically a
simple orchestrator i would say but
logic apps on on the other hand it's
more than that it's not just about
calling functions but it's about calling
any http driven
thing like not just functions but any
http service basically and it also has
more than just calling functions but the
logic basically that's why it's called
logic apps the logic to handle the calls
to pass the results to pass to call the
next service so i would say logic apps
encapsulates that and more
but maybe in a simple kind of use case
where you just need to call some other
functions maybe durable functions is the
way to go yeah and
yeah that's it
yeah
also there was something about
actors
which can be a good method for
implementing an orchestrator
is that something you see match um
so
i've had a look at some platforms like
account and things like that so
that's also another i would say valid
approach uh i don't have a personal
experience with these systems so
uh that's a bit complicated for me to uh
to contrast them and there was a
question but i think that disappeared
about um
monitoring etc so we're not really
focusing on this aspect uh but for
example on google cloud there are
various tools uh
for logging for monitoring creating
alerts etc so for example you see that
your workflow is failing
um lots of times on
career
workflows uh
so you could create alerts uh create
metrics and so on to track this and
create dashboards and so on but it's not
only the the focus
today
all right so um
my screen is shared so let me tell you
about this uh picker daily uh
application so pick a daily like
piccadilly circus in london but it's big
daily in the sense we share a picture a
day for example so it's an application
methane and i built um
a year or two ago actually before the
start of the pandemic and that we
rewrote recently using an orchestration
approach but initially we had created a
an even-driven
approach a choreography of events
so it's uh
this looks like this i'm going to to
show you a demonstration now basically
it's a
way to share pictures so anonymous users
can upload pictures
we're using machine learning to analyze
the pictures
and to check also if it's a picture that
we are allowed to display to avoid
showing bad things on screen
and
let me show you uh here so you see my my
app ripped yes uh so the app is here so
i've already uploaded a few pictures
perhaps i can
upload a new one
so let's uh
pictures uh
let's say here
i don't know which one i even uploaded
yet so let's leave a point on this one
submit um so you can there's a
page here uh for submitting pictures so
it's going to be processed but it's
going to appear in a short moment
there's a page uh where you can
see a collage of the four most recent
pictures and the home page
displays the older pictures but you can
see that there are some labels
that's the machine learning api that
we're calling the vision api that
analyzes pictures and finds uh the
labels of what's recognized in the
picture and there's also the colorful
border around the pictures because the
the vision api also analyzes things like
the the color color palette of the the
picture
and uh if i hit reload once more yeah
the new picture has been processed and
uploaded
and i can see my uh pictures from
the time where uh i i used to travel
uh in egypt that was a trip with my
family so we created this application
and here's
the
what it looks like in terms of
architecture
so here
i don't know if it works when i zoom in
do you see my my zoom
um no i will just see this line no okay
well never mind so
uh let me use this uh red pointer so a
user is going to upload a picture
uh through the web front end here i'm
using app engine as my web frontend
a picture is uploaded into a cloud
storage bucket
and here uh it's going to trigger some
events so when the picture lands into a
bucket it's going to trigger
the image analysis
function which is going to call the
cloud vision api
and
once the vision api returns we're going
to store some picture metadata here in
the cloud firestore
nosql
database
things like the name of the picture the
labels the color etc whether thumbnail
was created for the picture or not and
also in parallel uh we're also creating
the nails of pictures so that's another
service here uh this one was
a cloud function but this one is using
cloud run so it's a way to containerize
applications and run containers
serverlessly
so this one is creating thumbnails and
it's going to update the
database with
saying whether the thumbnail was created
generated or not and we're also going to
uh post or
save in another bucket the thumbnail of
the picture
uh what else on a regular interval of
time thanks to cloud scheduler we're
going to create a collage of the
pictures so
if there are new pictures we're going to
update the collage with the latest uh
stitched pictures together
we also created another service at the
bottom here the the garbage collection
service it's another cloud run uh
service you using you know a container
again
uh this uh service is gonna what's going
to happen is that uh if you're deleting
the full size picture
we also want automatically to have the
the thumbnail being deleted as well as
the metadata in
the database so it's a some garbage
collection to also clean
other things so you delete the big
picture it's deleting the thumbnail and
it's deleting uh the metadata so we had
um
basically events flying around
there are different ways to deal with
those events because we were using
different products
i think that's the yeah the next line so
for example for the so just showing a
few lines of the the headers of uh those
services so for example here i was
exporting um so we we implemented it
using node.js but we also have uh some
implementations in
c sharp and
java and some go as well in the
uh open source code there
um
so here we're using cloud functions
cloud functions
well you just receive an event and a
context about that event and the event
contains like the name of the file of
the the picture and the bucket in which
the file was stored but if you look at
another service this time we're going to
use
the i think that's the thumbnail
creation service
since we're using collaborant cloud 1 is
a
container service that receives http
request but here the events that are
flying around are actually cloud storage
events
so how do you pass such events to an
http an http based service like cloud
run
well
the thing is uh for cloudwork we have to
uh wrap
the uh well it's done automatically but
you have to do the unwrapping yourself
in your service
you you're receiving the cloud storage
even which is wrapped inside the pub sub
message and the pub sub message is
wrapped into an http request so that
they are it's like onions that you have
to to peel one layer after another so
it's a different way of dealing with
a needle
and the third
way that's for the
garbage collection service
this service is using the event arc
product which is a way to
direct uh
events from one place to another so
there are different uh
things and sources and things
you can have events
flying in different directions and even
the arc is using the cloud even
specification like the the sub os
workflow specification uh what's nice
with that is that you've got a
standardized um
syntax for for events but then again
that's another way to unwrap the data
within those events so you've got three
different ways
uh of dealing with uh events in that
particular
choreography uh
orchestrated uh choreographing
event driven system
and uh meta we reworked this application
we rewrote it to use an orchestrated
approach right
so i will describe that quickly
let me
so let me stop presenting
okay
so the event driven
we the reason why we went event driven
is that you know someone uploads a
picture and then that triggers an event
so it kind of made sense to follow that
event um
across different services right so that
was our initial design
but the the problem that we were running
into with that design is that even
though it was a quite simple
um kind of service with with a few
services not too many we were we were
already getting problems with complexity
like first
we had to deal with three different
event types and how to price those event
types and
you know how to deal with them and every
time we had to update something we had
to think about okay this is this service
receiving this type of event you know so
there was already complexity there
secondly when something failed let's say
the user uploaded the picture
and it didn't show up in our ui like we
didn't know why things failed like we
always had to kind of guess and we had
to always look at okay let's look at the
logs of this service do we say enter or
no okay let's look at the next one you
know and that's kind of the problem with
event driven systems is that
it makes it hard to trace things uh of
course you have things like error
reporting and you can do like
correlation ids and kind of try to trace
things but it's something you need to
think about and implement right it
doesn't come out of the box
so when workflows
came along at the beginning of this year
we said okay let's just take this and
try to orchestrate it because when you
think about it
we don't need the flexibility of full
eventing we want user to upload the
picture and then it triggers an event
and then from then on what needs to
happen is quite
actually quite clear and it needs to
happen in a certain order
so we did that we workflows and this is
architecture that we came up with
and when you first look at this it might
look a little bit uh more complicated
but actually anything in these boxes
it's one service it's workflows service
so if you think of this as one service
then it's actually simpler
and the way this works is that you know
we have the user front at the front end
uploading the picture to the storage
like before that triggers an event so in
that sense it's still event driven
that goes to a cloud function and then
from there the cloud function tree
starts the orchestration so it starts
the orchestration that we defined in
workflows now in this orchestration
we check the event type is it a new
object creation or is it a new image
deletion event if it's image deletion we
delete the image uh from storage and
from firestore so this happens within
workflows no new services
and if it's a new object
we call the vision api from workflows we
get the data from workflows and we need
to do json parsing so here we deploy a
function to do that and we check the
safety of the image within workflow
again and if it's safe we store in
firestore and then
if it's not safe we end the
orchestration and finally once the
picture is safe we make calls to
thumbnail service and collapse service
to create the thumbnail and collage of
the picture
so you can see that in this model we are
kind of combining couple of things like
we are first it's event driven but at
the end of the day that kicks on
orchestration secondly we are doing some
of the work in workflows
and some of the work by calling services
um
if it's simple enough we do it in
workflows but if it requires more logic
then we delegate to an external service
uh so that's the approach that we came
up with um
and i i think i can quickly show you
here we are running out of time but i
just want to just quickly show you here
if i go to google cloud
workflows
let me make this as big as possible
you can see that i have the workflow um
name and then we can we have the source
here
and
it's probably hard to see but here the
workflow is defined and you can you can
get this on github by the way uh but we
define all the steps what happens
and then there's a visualization here
that shows you
uh what should happen in different kind
of scenarios so this makes it really
easy to visualize what's happening
so that that's it uh with our workflows
i'm not going to run it because we're
almost out of time but we want to talk
about the
lessons learned here um
should i continue with this part or do
you want to take over yeah i was
going to take over but okay well yeah
let's
just finish it so we have
this
all the code is available on google
cloud platforms stabilized photo sharing
workshop so if you want to have a look
at the two approaches
um be sure to check this this link out
yeah so in terms of lessons learned uh
what was interesting was that as we
rewrote this application it was
refreshing to get back to using uh
simple rest calls instead of various
eventing formats that have to be had to
be uh that we had to deal with we also
had less code to handle so no even
parsing uh and also even some of our
services uh were going away because
services that were just calling some
other services or apis
they could just be done declaratively
within the yaml workflow definition we
also had less setup
because we didn't have to set up the pub
sub topics we didn't have to set up the
the scheduler
or even arc to create the the routes of
events in our system and it was also
easier for error handling because
the whole chain could stop on error and
we would know at which step it would
stop and and
so that was
easier to actually track errors and see
that okay that was this particular image
that triggered that problem instead of
having to go through the various
messages and understand which one is
correlated to to the other
and
the
other things that we learned along the
way so we we did the rewrite when uh the
workforce product wasn't yet uh ga so we
there were a few quirks and limited
documentation but fortunately
this has greatly improved uh in the past
month past year even
the thing you have to be aware of is
that
yaml is not a programming language okay
and
don't put too much in your workflow
definition what is a really a business
rule with logic etc uh it's probably
better you know in a function in a
service rather than uh in uh
yaml definition file and as well
testing
you can't really test yaml files right
uh so it's uh it's more complicated and
uh if you're trying to build too much
logic into your workflow instead of
simple checks and branching and so on
uh you don't have the same support as
with your id for your programming
language for example
also potentially you might have some
less some
well a bit less of parallelism or even
thing flexibility in the sense that you
have to test the whole workflow again
when there's a new event or something
new happening whereas with eventing with
choreography uh
usually it's really just adding an event
or well it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't run tests
but still it might be easier to add new
things and when i say loss of
parallelism uh it's that we tend to
write more sequentially in the workflow
definition
but uh parallelism is a feature that is
also coming to cloud workflows so uh we
don't necessarily lose uh polylision per
se
so that's about it we are out of time
here are a few links you might be
interested in uh in looking at with some
tips with some getting studied guides
and also some codelabs if you want to
get your hands on uh those technologies
so don't hesitate to um
to to ping us on twitter uh for further
questions as well and sorry for the font
size which was too small uh for you will
have to update the slides accordingly
yeah and uh there are a couple of
questions i know we are out of time but
i'll try to answer them quickly here um
so one question was
someone mentioned that they're using
logic apps for orchestration and their
experiences that they're hard to test
automatically and manually because they
cannot run locally
that's true that's true for workflows as
well workflows is a service there's no
local workflows
not not yet at least
so yeah
writing unit tests for them or running
them locally is a challenge we usually
just run against
like the cloud and it's really quick so
it doesn't really affect it as so much
in that sense but it's something to be
aware or maybe a drawback or use
orchestration services
and the
last question is in orchestration you
typically send events
that something happened but when
orchestrating you send commands and
async await for an event no i mean in
orchestration you send http calls
basically that's what it is um
and and you you wait for the result of
that http call um you can also send
events so for example workflows can send
a pops up message
um
that that's also possible but at the end
of the day just making http calls um
that's how it is
all right um
i think that's it um thanks everyone for
coming and sorry that we were not there
um hopefully this was useful to you
um if there's any other questions feel
free to reach out on reach us on twitter
and enjoy the rest of the conference
thanks very much
thank you bye